[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing an
incredibly scandalous topic why hermione
should have been with harry instead of
ron
for those of you who are primarily fans
of the harry potter novels or enjoy both
the books and the movies i imagine that
this particular sentiment sparks outrage
the very mention of the idea on the
other hand for all you movie loyalists
out there i'm fairly certain many of you
are likely nodding your heads along in
agreement and it is for this exact
reason that i'd like to further define
today's topic so that there is no
confusion on the matter that is i only
believe that hermione should have been
with harry in the film adaptation of the
harry potter series
now there are exactly three reasons for
why i feel this way and they all revolve
around the liberties that were taken
with ron hermione and harry's characters
when translating the books into films
as you may already be familiar with in
the past i've released a series of
videos discussing the major character
differences between these three best
mates when translated from page to
screen
if you're not familiar with them i
highly recommend you go check them out
they are three major differences between
book and movie hermione
four huge differences between movie and
book ron weasley and four huge
differences about harry movie watchers
won't know
essentially in these videos i break down
how both hermione and harry are made
into near-perfect versions of themselves
especially hermione whereas ron is
portrayed as a goofy buffoon version of
his book character
for harry the film seemed to have
removed his wittier more rebellious side
turning him into a hero with minimal
flaws in the case of hermione and ron
the writers simply seem to have taken
away a lot of ron's lines and important
moments and given them to hermione
degrading his character and enhancing
hers
as i explained in the other videos a
large component of this may have been to
simplify the source of information for
the audience that is by giving hermione
all of the educational lines in the
movies viewers would clue in that when
hermione was talking she was often
explaining things about the wizarding
world
in my opinion this was completely
unnecessary and really didn't make all
that much sense
for example while in the books yes
hermione was very intelligent when it
came to book learning it was ron who was
the source of information on how the
wizarding world worked this made great
sense since ron a pure blood wizard born
into a magical family had lived in this
world his entire life
hermione on the other hand was a
muggle-born witch who had no idea that
the wizarding world even existed until
she received her letter of acceptance
from hogwarts
in any case i digress but that's just a
little bit of backstory for you on some
of the major differences between the
book and film versions of these three
main characters
so with all this in mind i freely admit
that i don't believe hermione should
have been with harry in the novels in
fact in the book series hermione and ron
are well actually near perfect for one
another they support one another when it
counts and challenge each other in areas
in which the other has shortcomings plus
ron's a lot smarter in the book than he
is in the films so he really does keep
up with hermione's intelligence and
actually rather balances her book smarts
with his quick wit humor and valor
this very clearly is not the case in the
movies
a great example of this can be found in
one of the many differences between
scenes in the prisoner of azkaban this
particular instance takes place in
professor snape's potions class when he
asks the third year students a question
in both the book and movie version
hermione is extremely eager to respond
to the question since of course she
knows the answer
snape however simply refuses to call on
her and so she shares the answer with
the class without being asked here's how
the rest of that scene plays out in the
novel that is the second time you've
spoken out of turn miss granger said
snape coolly five more points from
gryffindor for being an insufferable
know-it-all hermione went very red put
down her hand and stared at the floor
with her eyes full of tears
it was a mark of how much the class
loathed snape that they were all glaring
at him because every one of them had
called hermione a noah tool at least
once and ron who told hermione she was a
know-it-all at least twice a week said
loudly you asked us a question and she
knows the answer why ask if you don't
want to be told
in great contrast when hermione shares
the answer to snape's question out of
turn in the movie and alan rickman snape
reprimands her for being an inseparable
know at all do you remember what rupert
grint's portrayal of ron says he's got a
point you know i mean no wonder movie
lovers of the harry potter franchise
don't think ron deserves to be with this
flawless and beautiful version of
hermione as portrayed by emma watson
not only is he not that bright but he's
also a complete jerk
sadly this sort of lost in translation
adaptation from book to film seems to be
quite common as there are several other
scenes in which the novels portray ron
as acting in hermione's best interest or
standing up for her or harry but in the
movies he's either rude silent or the
scene simply doesn't exist
quite honestly i don't envy the job the
screenwriters were tasked with when
writing all seven harry potter scripts
cutting five to eight hundred page books
down into two hour movies would be no
easy task but i simply don't agree with
many of these script changes that
fundamentally altered ron's relationship
with hermione and that's not to say
anything about what it did to his
friendship with harry i mean our movie
ron and harry even best friends it
doesn't really seem so does it
there are also multiple scenarios that
the films portray that never take place
in the books
many of which make it seem like hermione
and harry would be much better suited
for one another than hermione and ron
for example in the movie version of the
half blood prince we see harry
comforting her crying hermione in one of
the towers at hogwarts as you may recall
she's crying in the scene because she's
upset that ron is dating lavender brown
and while book ron may have also dated
lavender brown we are never presented
with the scene in which hermione cries
on harry's shoulder
in fact he seems to only notice that
she's been crying in passing
with descriptions from the book sounding
something more like this
harry thought he had a swamp before the
door slammed
there's also that scene at the end of
the half blood prince when all three
friends are still at hogwarts and harry
is sharing that he doesn't plan on
returning to hogwarts the following year
and will instead be tracking down
voldemort's horcruxes
in an effort to defeat the dark lord
once and for all
here's how it all goes down in the book
we'll be there harry said ron
what at your aunts and uncle's house
said ron and then we'll go with you
wherever you're going no said harry
quickly he hadn't counted on this he'd
meant them to understand that he was
undertaking the most dangerous journey
alone
you said it once before said hermione
quickly that there was time to turn back
if he wanted to we've had time haven't
we we're with you whatever happens
by contrast in the movies ron sits
laughably far away from hermione and
harry as the two h's plan their future
together harry i'm not coming back
hermione i've got to finish whatever
dumbledore started and i don't know
where that'll lead me but i'll let you
and ron know where i am when i can
hermione i've always admired your
courage harry but sometimes you can be
really thick you don't really think
you're going to be able to find all
those horcruxes by yourself do you you
need us harry so of course with uh
enhancements like this littered
throughout the films it seems just so
obvious that hermione should be with
harry and certainly not that dalt ron
all in all when it comes to the movies
i'm all for the hermione harry ship or
as some fans like to call them harmony
okay maybe i wouldn't go quite that far
but with that we've come to the end of
another video
what did you think do you agree should
movie hermione and harry have been
together maybe you even think book
mainly and harry should have been
together or perhaps you believe that
both film and novel ron was the right
match for hermione let me know your
thoughts in the comments below and as
always if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel until next time
honestly don't you two read
you